invités politiques ce matin c'est
valencia pas bonjour j'ai aussi beaucoup
d'être avec nommé délégué chargé de la
citoyenneté en est ensemble pendant 25
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
est qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest-france - jean-stéphane
bonjour et on commence marlène échappe
évidemment par la crise sanitaire et
cette question que tout le monde attend
emmanuel macron va-t-il prendre la
parole dans les prochaines heures
va-t-il s'adresser aux français
moi je n'ai pas d'information et là je
ne suis pas vous annoncer la date de
prise de parole du président la
république
je crois qu'en tout cas c'est important
car intervalles réguliers un exercice de
transparence
c'est ce que le gouvernement fait depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire qu'il
s'agisse des points d'olivier ferrand
des points et des annonces du 1er jean
castex ou des prises de parole du
président de la république qui est très
engagée évidemment pour permettre de
résoudre au plus vite cette crise
sanitaire qui nous impacte tous est-ce
qu'il peut prendre la parole sans faire
d'annoncés fortes
ce soir par exemple s'il prenait la
parole je veux pas me perdre en
conjectures parce que je ne veux pas que
mes propos soient mal interprétés mais
je crois que c'est comme je disais je
crois que c'est important qu'ils aient
des prises de parole qu'il y ait des
annonces ou pad annonce on voit que le
prix dans la république pardon s'est
déplacé à plusieurs reprises sur le
terrain pour soutenir le dispositif
allait vers notamment qui est un
dispositif important qui permet d'aller
chercher les personnes de plus de 75 ans
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés est ce que
c'est vrai qu'on a des gens enfin moi je
les ai vu aussi dans ma famille dans mes
proches des gens qui me disaient pas
j'attends qu'on m'appelle est donc là
l'idée c'est de dire toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas fait la démarche
proactive d'aller prendre un rendez vous
se faire vacciner on va maintenant
essayer de les identifier
pour leur proposer un vaccin et faire en
sorte d'avoir vraiment couverte ou 100 m
et sur les mesures et la stratégie du
gouvernement que j'entendais les
pressions du corps médical
est ce que on peut faire autre chose que
re confiné à l'heure actuelle au moins
dans les départements très touchée
notamment l'ile-de-france
j'entends honnêtement moi je veux pas
rajouter du brouhaha aux voix parce que
chacun donne son avis sur il faudrait je
trouve que c'est très confuse ans pour
les français d'ailleurs quand chacun
jette une proposition sur un plateau
télévision après à venir il parle trop
les médecins pour vous non pas des
médecins nécessairement mais je parle
aussi de ceux d'un certain nombre de
responsables politiques cherchent sont
chacun donne son avis
vous voulez si je change je me
positionne comme citoyenne et que
j'écoute les avis des uns et des autres
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de mesures
qui sont jetés comme ça et à la fin
c'est assez confuse en compte la
situation est déjà très compliquée donc
tenons nous en aux mesures qui sont
annoncées par le gouvernement et que
chacun doit respecter c'est mon humble
avis en tout cas et ça ce sera tranché
ce matin uniquement ce matin devant le
conseil de défense vous avez vu les
trois scénarios qui circulent depuis
depuis hier soir entre l'idée de
transférer des médecins par exemple de
fermer les écoles uniquement dans les
départements ou les régions les plus
touchées
ou alors le statu quo c'est à dire pour
l'instant hulu pardon le leur
confinement dur oui mais la défense vous
avez raison de le rappeler
tout à l'heure et chacun doit pouvoir
faire valoir les nécessités qui sont les
siennes moi j'étais avec le premier
ministre à valence samedi et nous nous
sommes rendus dans un vaccinodromes en
tout cas dans un dans un dans un hôpital
dans lequel il y avait un dispositif de
vaccins et je voudrais si on ne
permettait en profiter pour saluer
encore le travail des soignants
parce qu'on a vu vraiment des personnes
très mobilisés par exemple une
infirmière scolaire qui est venu prêter
main forte à l'hôpital des cadres
administratifs qui d'habitude on
d'autres métiers qui se sont organisés
pour faire une chaîne d'inscription pour
que les personnes puissent à venir se
faire vacciner
je crois que c'est un travail difficile
qui est en train d'être menées en
tension les personnels soignants les
pompiers aussi qu'ils participent
maintenant de plus en plus dans beaucoup
territoire en corse et ailleurs aux
opérations de vaccination
je crois que c'est important de saluer
cette belle mobilisation parce que le
vaccin c'est notre lumière au bout du
tunnel c'est quand nous seront vaccinés
majoritairement que nous pourrons
reprendre une vie le plus normale entre
guillemets alors justement sur le vaccin
est ce qu'il faut un peu changé
stratégie est ce que par exemple il faut
avancer là va signer la vaccination des
enseignants et ne pas attendre mi avril
ou fin avril mais à présent la
république s'est exprimé sur ce sujet en
rappelant que notre stratégie c'est de
vacciner d'abord les plus fragiles les
plus faibles et je trouve que c'est
évidemment normal de se dire que les
plus âgés les plus anciens ceux qui ont
le plus de risques face à la pandémie
bien on veut les protéger et on veut les
vacciner pour qu'ils et elles puissent
être mieux protégés et puis retrouver
aussi leurs familles vous avez
probablement jcc campagne à la
télévision avec une dame
qui retrouve ses petits enfants après
avoir été vaccinée c'est très émouvant
de se projeter dans ces retrouvailles
pour des personnes qui ont été un peu
isolé et on le sait à quelle place au
dessus pour les enseignants du 1 pour
les enseignants présents un clic s'est
prononcé en ce sens qu'ils souhaitent
puissent être vaccinés parce qu'ils sont
évidemment au contact des enfants les
mesures qui ont été annoncées sont
importants sur les écoles pareil là vous
pensez vous pouvez encore maintenir
votre ligne vous voyez le nombre de
classes fermées augmente augmenté
augmentaient ce que de toute façon on
n'est pas dans un enseignement dégradée
dans les zones touchées
la situation elle est difficile et je
crois qu'il ya un principe de précaution
qui veut que dès lors qu'il ya un enfant
qui est atteint du cosy d' eh bien on
puisse fermer la classe pour faire en
sorte d'être très prudents pour ne pas
créer de foyers ou de clusters dans les
établissements scolaires un dernier mot
sur ce sujet vous avez sans doute vu
hier ces images sur les quais de saône à
lyon images de centaines de jeunes qui
se sont rassemblés pour faire la fête
souvent non masqué est ce que vous dites
que ce sont des comportements
irresponsables
absolument c'est irresponsable c'est
organiser un tel événement et participer
à un tel événement c'est totalement
irresponsable
d'ailleurs la préfecture s'est
énormément mobilisés immédiatement pour
y apporter des réponses
mais les sanctions plus sévères face à
ce type de comportement à des sanctions
qui existe il ya des verbalisations
après on voit bien que là on est dans
une situation difficile parce que vous
avez une foule massée par ailleurs aux
abords de la zone est donc bien
évidemment on ne veut pas crier qu'il y
ait de drame au moment des interventions
donc c'est une situation très difficile
pour les forces de l'ordre que de
mesurer entre la possibilité de
disperser ce rassemblement qui est qui
et bien sûr fort et moi j'ai envie
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
ce rassemblement à aller d'abord se
faire tester et ensuite à s'isoler
parce que là on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
de personnes la majorité des gens sont
sans masque ne respecte pas du tout les
mesures sanitaires proportionnellement
dans la foulée il ya très certainement
des gens qui sont positifs aux causes il
est donc vraiment je les appelle
maintenant avoir un sursaut de
responsabilité faire un test dans une
pharmacie ou prendre rendez vous chez le
médecin et ensuite si isolé pendant
plusieurs jours jusqu'au résultat du
test
on va parler des régionales puisque la
crise sanitaire risque d'avoir un impact
sur les régionales le conseil
scientifique a rendu son avis
il n'a pas vraiment trancher est-ce qu'à
la lecture de cet avis vous êtes
favorable à un report des régionales ou
à son leur maintien à l'ao date annoncée
mais vous avez absolument raison de le
rappeler c'est cet avis du conseil
scientifique et bien il ne tranche pas
dans un sens ou dans un lot s'il ne fait
pas véritablement de recommandation ni
dans un sens ni dans l'autre
donc moi c'est moi qui aurais à
l'honneur de représenter le gouvernement
je dis donc demain au sénat pour être
auditionné sur le rapport que le
gouvernement va mettre que vous vous
souvenez que nous avions nous étions
engagés dans les débats au sénat et au
parlement à remettre avant le 1er avril
au plus tard un rapport basé sur cet
avis du conseil scientifique au
parlement et puis in fine et ce sera si
jamais il devait y avoir une proposition
de report du gouvernement ce sera au
parlement de trancher
au final puisque nous sommes obligés de
passer par une nouvelle loi le
gouvernement seul ne peut pas décider de
reporter les élections régionales il y
aurait forcément une nouvelle loi donc à
ce stade moi je crois que le premier de
jean castex est en train d'écouter les
uns et les autres avant avait juste pour
qu'on soit clair ça veut dire que le
parlement ne sera consulté uniquement en
cas de report et donc d'une nouvelle loi
où il sera consulté quoi qu'il arrive
avec un débat notamment via l'arctique
saint quentin et vous lui demanderez
vous demanderez aux parlementaires leur
position le parlement est consulté quoi
qu'il arrive puisque dans tous les cas
il ya la remise de ce rapport et ça
c'est nous qui nous y étions engagés
pour associer pleinement les
parlementaires dont par l'onu arrive y
aura un débat au parlement à leur vote
alors je ne sais pas qui aura un débat
avec vote ça il appartient au parlement
notamment par exemple au sénat de
décider moi je suis auditionné par la
commission des loges je me permets
d'être technique emmené son public sénat
qui connaissent bien le fonctionnement
les gens qui vous regardent
moi je suis auditionné par la commission
des lois du sénat demain c'est ce qui
est prévu jusqu'à ce jour jusqu'au
moment où je vous parle maintenant le
sénat peut aussi décider qui ne
souhaitent pas auditionner la mine
chargé de la citoyenneté et qui a porté
ses projets de lois sur les élections
ils peuvent aussi décider qu'il convoque
effectivement un débat et que le premier
ministre est bien vivant avec eux au
sénat débattre de ces questions mais moi
je vous réserve
là ça c'est le mot ça c'est le comment
je crois que la vraie question c'est le
coin au delà de parce qu'en fait trouver
les modus operandi du débat ça on y
arrive toujours
et c'est bien évidemment souhaitable la
vraie question c'est le couac est ce
qu'on fait quelles sont les mesures
sanitaires que l'on prend pour faire en
sorte que les élections puissent se
tenir que ce soit en juin ou en
septembre ou en octobre
parce que dans tous les cas il ya des
mesures sanitaires à prendre le rapport
du conseil scientifique il recommande
par exemple la vaccination des
assesseurs des personnes qui vont venir
on sait que dans une élection ce qui
fait l'élection c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui généreusement parce qu'ils ont un
engagement citoyen pour la démocratie
viennent kahniens les bureaux on a
besoin de pouvoir les plus justes
stéphane juste pour qu'on soit bien
clair
marlène schiappa est ce que ça veut dire
que demain devant les sénateurs vous
arriverait avec une position claire du
gouvernement en disant on est pour
on est content le report ou est ce que
vous direz aux sénateurs on n'a pas de
position gouvernement c'est à vous de
décider ça il appartient en premier
ministre jean castex de décider quelle
sera la position du gouvernement et moi
n'est pas décidé à l'heure actuelle ça
alors ce que je vous dis c'est que moi
je pourrais l'annoncé au moment de
l'audition près de la commission des
lois est réservé aux sénateurs qu'ils
m'en voudrait beaucoup de donner une
position avancée très bien mais vous
donnerez une position ce que vous dites
c'est que vous donnerez un os nous nous
ferons des propositions après vous voyez
bien que le débat politique est biaisé à
l'heure actuelle parce que si on est
très honnête
entre nous on sait très bien que si le
gouvernement dit nous on veut à tout
prix les maintenir en juin il ya des
gens qui vont nous dire bah non il faut
les reporter pourquoi voulait maintenir
c'est pas raisonnable etc
et si on dit nous on veut absolument les
décalés vous avez des gens qui vont vous
dire bah pourquoi vous les décalés c'est
louche c'est une manipulation etc
on est soupçonné dans tous les cas si
vous voulez donc moi je crois que cette
décision doit être collégiale partager
et c'est pourquoi je pense que pr
ministre a raison d'écouter les uns et
les autres et notamment les responsables
des grands partis policiers pour des
grandes formations comme ici au bout du
bout le calendrier c'est quoi quand est
ce qu'on saura si ces élections elles
sont oui ou non ont maintenu ou décalée
alors le calendrier le calendrier il a
été voté lors du projet de loi pour
reporter justement les élections
régionales j'ai défendu au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale les parlementaires
ont décidé qu'il y avait donc sur cette
remise du rapport donc le calendrier
au planning les étapes c'est que le 1er
avril il y à cette remise de rapports et
ensuite il y à des échanges et s'il
s'avérait je suis bien au conditionnel
je sais ce que je veux pas qu une
dépêche afp dix ans alors elle chapelle
sous-entend un report et c'est pas le
cas au conditionnel s'il s'avérait qu'il
y avait une proposition de report des
élections
il y aurait un nouveau projet loi et
donc manifestement ce nouveau projet de
loi il adviendrait plusieurs semaines
avant la date prévue des élections qui
était prévue le 13 qui sont prévus le 13
et le 20 juin
donc ça veut dire là dans les semaines à
venir mais là on est vraiment dans
l'étape d'après après après pour
l'instant je pense qu'il faut qu'on se
concentre sur la remise de ce rapport
les parlementaires n'ont pas encore
connaissance
c'est fondamental pour nous d'avoir
aussi les retours est de savoir ce que
pensent les grandes formations
politiques qui pour l'instant ne se sont
pas prononcés sur cette question posée
pas de report des élections les choses
cachées dans combien dans quels délais
en fait ce cas une campagne derrière si
on a les élections effectivement juin
faut que les choses allaient medad de
délai de campagne elles ont été votés
dans le cadre du projet doit donc il ya
plusieurs semaines avant le premier tour
le premier tour a lieu le 13 juin et
donc la campagne l on ait lieu les
semaines qui précèdent comme celle
usages habituellement mais ça si vous
voulez je pense qu'on est là et chacun
le comprend parfaitement
à commencer par attend en fait pour
examiner tout ce à quoi vous avez vous
allez vous donner du temps le temps
nécessaire pour examiner exactement et
je pense que les sénateurs et les
sénatrices qui sont vraiment aux prises
avec les territoires savent très bien
qu'il y a une
volonté d'aller voter je crois que les
élections régionales ont dû beaucoup
qu'elle n'intéresse pas mais moi
j'observe c'est quand même beaucoup de
français qui veulent s'exprimer d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est la
démocratie
mais je crois qu'ils ont aussi des
retours des préoccupations des français
sur la façon dont ils ont la classe
politique aujourd'hui fait ça fait plus
débat en fait c'est la volonté que ces
élections aient lieu en juin corbeau moi
j'ai entendu certains se prononcer mais
pas forcément clairement et par tout le
monde on entend des choses
officiellement des choses officieusement
comme je disais tout à l'heure on a tous
dans votre camp d'ailleurs notamment le
modem est opposé à un maintien de la
date au mois de juin pas forcément pas
tout le monde au modèle en tout cas
c'est parce que j'ai entendu je veux pas
parler évidemment de pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour cette formation
politique mais je crois que encore une
fois on sait qu'on a vu beaucoup de gens
je parle évidemment pas pour le modem et
on a vu beaucoup de responsables
politiques changé d'avis pour être en
opposition à ce que propose le
gouvernement en fonction des annonces du
gouvernement donc là on aimerait aussi
que chacun prenne position s'explique et
s'exprime par dont ils disent clairement
je suis pour un dernier mot marlène
schiappa sur cet avis du conseil
scientifique parce que dans cet avis le
conseil scientifique qui regrette aussi
que la digitalisation des votes et le
vote par correspondance ne put n puisse
être envisagée pour ce scrutin est ce
que le gouvernement
il a un peu failli dans l'adaptation des
modalités du scrutin la crise sanitaire
moi je crois pas parce qu'encore une
fois le parlement c'est une chambre de
débat mais aussi une chambre de décision
et donc il ya eu un certain nombre
d'amendements pour améliorer ou pour
modifier le mode de scrutin que ce soit
venant des parlementaires ou du
gouvernement
des parlementaires de tous les bords et
la plupart des amendements qui proposait
d'aller plus loin n'ont pas été retenus
à part la double procuration et puis il
ya une question de débat autour de la
déterritorialisation du vote vous les
avez suivi à la fois pour les régionales
et pour les élections présidentielles
mais moi je m'observe qui a des comptes
gao zhiyi des propositions des
parlementaires sur le vote par
correspondance jouit position du
gouvernement qui n'ont pas été retenus
sur le vote par exemple par machine à
voter par anticipation etc
mais sur le fait par correspondance moi
j'entends la préoccupation sanitaire
il ya aussi une préoccupation de
démocratique à l'heure actuelle et je
vous le dis étant mise de la citoyenneté
et au ministère de l'intérieur ce sont
aux services qui sont en charge la
question de l'organisation des élections
en ce qui concerne le vote par
correspondance à l'heure actuelle pour
des délais si bref nous ne sommes pas en
mesure matériellement d'organiser la
sécurité et la sincérité d'un vote par
correspondance je ne dis pas que je sois
contre de façon empirique mais là nous
avons essayé philosophiquement pour oui
mais on a pas mal à ne même pas la
possibilité de sécuriser ce vote y
compris de savoir par exemple si les
personnes qui vote par correspondance
n'ont pas subi de pressions et la
période sanitaire d'isolement des uns et
des autres ne n'est pas favorable à mon
humble avis à ce type de vote mais je
comprend enfin les médecins se prononce
avec des considérations scientifiques et
qu'ils ont bien raison et nous nous
prononçons aussi avec les considérations
démocratique un dernier mot sur cette
campagne des régionales est
particulièrement en ile de france
puisque la candidate audrey pulvar a eu
des propos qui ont fait parlé en disant
que lors des réunions
demandez aux personnes blanches de se
taire alors hier dans le monde à la
préciser ses propos elle a dit j'ai
utilisé le verbe se taire parce que
c'est généralement ce que l'on fait
quand on veut réellement écouté l'autre
avant ensuite de prendre la parole
d'aucuns y ont vu une forme de sommation
au silence à tort qu est ce que vous
pensez de cette explication
je suis pas convaincu pour être très
honnête parce que quand on a des propos
et qu'on a des propos maladroits sur un
plateau télévision et ça arrive à tous
je donne de leçons évidemment à personne
quand on répond à de longues interviews
et qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de le faire
elle avait l'habitude peut-être plus de
poser les questions n'est pas d'apporter
des réponses sans savoir qu'on était
scrutée sa réponse à l été elle a
prononcé ces mots elle a prononcé ces
phrases si c'était si claire au parti
socialiste il y aurait eu un
rectificatif immédiatement or pendant
plusieurs jours ce qu'on a vu sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est que la candidate
aux régionales ile-de-france pour le
parti socialiste a partagé notamment des
défenses y compris des défenses qui
venaient de personnes qui sont proches
des idées indigéniste moi je crois qu'il
est inadmissible de demander aux gens de
se taire en fonction de leur couleur de
peau quel que soit le motif
tout comme il est inadmissible de
discriminer des personnes en raison de
leur couleur de peau et je les dis à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il s'agisse de
leur refuser un logement de leur refuser
un emploi ou de leur demander de se
taire on ne combat pas l'exclusion par
une autre forme d'exclusion et je crois
que ce débat illustre parfaitement
l'ambiguïté qui existe au sein de la
gauche et même je le déplore au sein du
parti socialiste entre une ligne
universaliste républicaine et une ligne
plus proche dit long de la ligne de
l'unef d'europe écologie les verts qui
est cette ligne un peu à la remorque des
idées indigéniste elle est on va parler
du texte que les sénateurs
des bus ont commencé à débattre hier
c'est bien sûr le projet de loi
comportant les principes de la
république alors d'abord ils veulent
changer le nom de ce texte certains
sénateurs ils veulent qui figure le mot
séparatisme est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ça non je suis favorable à
ce que le titre du texte reste en l'état
mais ensuite là encore il ya un vote et
les sénateurs sont souvent tout comme
l'ont été les députés mais moi je crois
que ce texte c'est un texte qui est
aussi un texte pour qu'elles un texte
pour conforter les principes
républicains
il ya un certain nombre de dispositifs
par exemple qui concerne aussi les
dérives sectaires
donc ils vont faire des choses qui ne
sont pas en lien direct avec l'islamisme
notre notre ce que nous voulons
combattre notre ennemi principal c'est
évidemment l'islamisme radical
mais il ya aussi des dispositifs par
exemple je pense à la question des
certificat de virginité forcés à la
question des dérives sectaires que
j'évoquais à l'instant qui sont aussi
partie intégrante de ce texte et qui
doivent y rester à mon humble avis de la
question du voile a été remis sur la
table les sénateurs ont voté
l'interdiction des signes religieux pour
les accompagnants des accompagnateurs de
sorties scolaires
est-ce que ça ça fait partie des choses
qui qui vous convienne ou qui me pose
problème
moi je ne suis pas favorable et la
position du gouvernement et l'ensemble a
été a été clair sur ce sujet d'ailleurs
les députés avaient voté contre cette
disposition à plusieurs reprises je vais
vous dire pourquoi je suis très
favorable à de grands principes pour moi
qui sont des principes fondateurs le
principe de laïcité
1 la liberté de conscience et la liberté
de conscience et la liberté de pouvoir
marcher dans la rue aller chercher ses
enfants à l'école avec un voile une
kippa une croix que sais-je
ça c'est la liberté de conscience et
puis par ailleurs la neutralité
religieuse de l'état et des services
publics ça c'est le fait que quand on
est au guichet des impôts ou de tel ou
tel service public et bien on ne porte
aucun signe distinctif parce que la
république vous accueille là comme
citoyen indifféremment de votre religion
il y avait ce débat de savoir est ce que
les mères qui accompagne une des sorties
scolaires sont des accompagnatrices et
des collaboratrices occasionnels du
service public prolongation de l'école
exactement auquel cas elles ont les
considérerait comme assimilés
fonctionnaires et elle n'aurait pas le
droit de porter un signe religieux ou
est-ce qu'elles sont là en tant que
parent d'élève
elles sont bénévoles est donc un contrat
elles ne représentent pas l'école auquel
cas elles ont le droit d'avoir un signe
religieux comme un pape a le droit de
porter sa kippa
quand il accompagne cette sortie
scolaire moi je suis attaché à ce
dernier principe le conseil d'état
d'ailleurs s'est prononcée juridiquement
sur cette question et je ne crois pas
honnêtement pour combattre l'islamisme
de cette manière là en empêchant une
maman tient en foulard d'accompagner une
sortie scolaire
j'ai été élu local je sais à quel point
c'est difficile d'engager les parents
dans l'accompagnement en tant que parent
d'élève dans l'école donc je crois que
ça n'est pas souhaitable et ce avec la
droite sénatoriale est là elle a attaqué
assez fort et hier il ya eu comme le
disait stéphane l'interdiction des
signes religieux lors des sorties
scolaires il ya aussi l'interdiction du
burkina dans les piscines l'interdiction
du voile pour les mineurs qu'est ce que
vous voyez dans cet ensemble
d'amendements dans l'engouement est ce
que vous dites il ya des visées
politiques
oui mais c'est pas un gros mot d'avoir
des visées politiques je leur fais pas
grief
en revanche nous nous sommes attachés
vous savez cette fois le prix dans la
république l'a voulue depuis maintenant
plusieurs années elle a été travaillé
avec gérald darmanin depuis huit mois
maintenant nous les travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec de larges
consultations pour qu'elles fassent
aussi consensus parce que je crois que
notre ennemi qui est le terreau du
terrorisme qui est l'islamisme radical
il est important de se battre contre cet
ennemi avec un consensus le plus large
possible et donc cette fois elle a été
travaillé notamment pour viser
l'efficacité
il ya des dispositifs qui ont été votées
qui encore une fois c'est mon avis mais
ne vise pas à l'efficacité sur la
question du burkina moi je suis très
opposé au port du burkini dans les
piscines municipales je les y à de
nombreuses reprises nous étions
d'ailleurs quelques-uns et nous étions
un peu sale lorsqu à grenoble il ya eu
une action coup de poing avec des gens
qui sont venus en burqini dans une
piscine municipale a dénoncé cette
action gérald darmanin a écrit notamment
à l'europe aux instances européennes
pour dire qu'il ne souhaitait plus qu'on
finance en tout cas qui l'interrogeait
sur le financement d'une organisation
alliance citoyenne qui promeut le port
du burkini dans les piscines municipales
mais y adhérer
mon intérieur tout relève pas de la loi
il ya des choses qui relèvent de la loi
des choses qui relèvent des règlements
du réglementaire est ce que c'était a
laissé un lieu les élus locaux seuls
faits relevés çà alors et dans cette loi
justement on soutient vraiment les élus
locaux par exemple avec le contrat
d'engagement républicain grâce au
contrat d'engagement républicains une
association qui demanderaient des
subventions mais qui ferait des actions
coup de poing pour le porter le burqini
au mépris du règlement intérieur des
piscines municipales
ce contrat d'engagement républicain que
je propose dans cette fois il permettra
de couper les vivres de cette
association et sera très utile à un
certain nombre d'élus et de
municipalités
alors il fait des bains la gauche par
exemple a dit qu'il ya déjà une charte d
engagement réciproque qui date de 2001
et que ce contrat d'engagement des
républicains il n'apporte pas forcément
grand-chose de plus qu'est ce que vous
dites à sa ba plusieurs choses d'abord
c'est la charge et beaucoup de respect
pour cette charte des engagements
réciproques mais d'abord elle n'a aucune
valeur contraignante elle n'a aucune
valeur juridique
et d'ailleurs c'est bien ça qui m'a
poussé à faire ce contrat d'engagement
républicain et à le proposer
c'est que j'ai eu beaucoup d'échangés
avec des élus des élus du parti
socialiste derrière je peux enfin je
peux citer michael delafosse maire de
montpellier mais aussi des élus avec la
mf avec lesquels nous avons échangé et
d'autres qui nous disent justement est
devant nous nous avons voulu faire des
chartes
mais ces chartes elles ont parfois été
attaqué en justice valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région ile de france
avait essayé de faire une charte sa
charte a été attaqué en justice et elles
n'étaient pas reconnus à n'avait aucune
valeur juridique
donc il ya des intentions que je partage
mais ils n'arrivent pas à les
concrétiser
nous avec cette fois nous voulons
soutenir les élus locaux qui sont
courageux comme le maire de montpellier
du ps et d'autre et leur proposer cette
charte qui a maintenant valeur de loi et
donc qui est contraignante et qui
permettra non seulement de mettre fin
aux subventions mais aussi de demander
le remboursement des subventions
vous savez un maire europe ecologie les
verts le maire de grenoble qui a s'est
aperçu qu'il avait malencontreusement
financer le ccf pendant des années ccf
organisation proche des sueurs
islamistes et qui a été dissoute en
conseil des ministres sur proposition du
musée l'intérieur et du président la
république
et bien grâce aux contrats d'engagement
républicain il aurait pu par exemple
demandé
au ccf le remboursement des subventions
qui ont été versés je rappelle que c'est
de l'argent public c'est de l'argent des
impôts agir vis-à-vis des associations
mais qu'est ce que vous allez faire avec
les municipalités qui autorise par
exemple le port du burkini dans les
piscines dans leur règlement intérieur
alors là nous avons proposé un certain
nombre de dispositifs notamment celui
qui est dit de carence républicaine pour
permettre justement aux préfets et aux
représentants de l'état dans les
territoires d'intervenir dès lors qu'il
ya des délibérations qui ne sont pas
conformes aux principes républicains je
pense par exemple à la subvention qui
vient d'être votée récemment par la
maire europe ecologie les verts de
strasbourg qui a décidé de donner deux
millions et demi d'euros à une mosquée
la mosquée de l'organisation me yvon
russe est bien là typiquement si cette
loi était entré en vigueur
l'état aurait davantage de matière pour
agir c'est la même chose sur les
fermetures d'établissements salut nous
réunissent mantoue les bises contre
strasbourg il ya un statut un peu
particulier qui a hérité de la période
1870 1914 et qui permet qui permet aux
collectivités de financer les grilles
culte absolu moi ce qu'on peut pas faire
dans le résultat
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
illégal du coup alors vous avez raison
mais les règles concordataire elles ne
disent pas à aucun moment vous êtes
obligés de financer une mosquée proche
de l'islamisme radical
j'entends que c'est écologique en tant
qu'europe écologie les verts se cache
derrière l'irak concordataire en disant
c'est pas nous c'est le concorde a enfin
quand on est aux responsabilités je te
dis non nos colonnes les règles existent
les ré qu'est ce qu'elle faisait là
concordataire elles disent que vous
pouvez consacrer une part de votre
budget au financement effectivement de
lieux de culte mais elles ne disent pas
que vous êtes obligé de choisir la
mosquée qui a refusé de s'engager dans
la charte des cinq fédérations de
l'islam et donc il refuse de reconnaître
la prévalence des lois
absolument et je sais plus de quoi on
parlait précédemment
pardon j'ai perdu ici la mosquée de
strasbourg le financement exactement oui
voilà j'allais vous parlez dclear des
cellules de lutte contre l'islamisme et
le repli communautaire qui sont d un
sens que nous réunissons dans tous les
départements autour des préfets et en
lien avec le procureur de la république
et qui passent au peigne fin tous les
lieux qui sont des foyers de séparatisme
et nous avons depuis 2018 fait fermer
cinq cent trente trois établissements
débits de boisson commerces associations
etc qui prétendait avoir une activité
mais qui en réalité faisait de
l'idéologie islamiste
nous les avons fait fermer avec la
diligence des services de l'état mais
c'était parfois difficile avec cette
fois il sera plus facile maintenant de
faire fermer ces lieux qui représentent
un vrai danger pour la république
je veux rappeler ce que j'ai entendu des
débats ces derniers jours je vous
rappeler qu'on est bien là en train de
parler d'islamisme radical et donc de ce
qui est le terreau du terrorisme
l'idéologie qui nourrit les personnes
qui ont décapité le professeur samuel
pâti dans la rue aux actions à mener a
égorgé des personnes dans une église à
nice
récemment c'est de cela dont on parle un
dernier mot sur un sujet qui inquiète
aussi les les élus avec ses fans les
élus qui sont plus que jamais victimes
d'agressions les agressions qui augmente
encore et encore stéphane oui en fait on
a vu qu'il y avait eu 300 agressions
physiques ou verbales en 2020 c'est 200
% de plus par rapport à l'année
précédente
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire par rapport à ceux à ce
phénomène qui est en très forte
augmentation est ce qu'il faut renforcer
les sanctions pénales est ce qu'il ya
d'autres leviers vous pouvez utiliser
pour combattre ce type de phénomène
agresser les élus c'est agressé la
république etc agressé la démocratie non
je déplore le fait qu'il y ait une
violence une virulence dans le débat
public qui fait que maintenant on arrive
très vite à la menace de mort en réalité
ça me ça me sidère il ya une escalade
c'est à dire quand on n'est pas d'accord
avec vous la location physique est
exactement où l'agression physique vous
avez raison on arrive à la violence en
fait quand vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
quelqu'un le premier réflexe on le voit
sur les réseaux sociaux
je reçois tous les jours des menaces de
or divers et variés de toute nature soit
sérieuse soit qui émane de troll on va
les appeler de cette manière mais je
vois que le débat une passe vite à
l'agression physique et les élus ils
sont en première ligne
on a souvent dit qu un maire ou un élu
local c'était quelqu'un qui était à
portée d'engueulades bas je souhaite
qu'ils soient pas apporté d'agression
évidemment nous nous sommes avec les
élus en plein soutien quelle que soit
leur couleur politique pour dire que le
débat il doit se faire sur le plan des
idées jamais sur le plan des personnes
est évidemment pas physiquement et
d'ailleurs dans sa vallée renforcer les
sanctions pénales dans ce projet doit
justement il ya des dispositions qui
permettent notamment de protéger les
élus mais mais pas uniquement toutes les
personnes qui représente les valeurs de
la république les enseignants les
policiers etc
lorsqu'on dévoile par exemple des
informations privées sur les réseaux
sociaux
ce qu'on voit c'est une nouvelle mode
entre guillemets j'allais dire avec des
gens qui quand ils veulent attaquer un
élu ou un professeur un policier dévoile
sur les réseaux sociaux des informations
personnelles par exemple votre adresse
ces cas pour des journalistes aussi
d'ailleurs
l'adresse où on peut vous trouver à
telle personne sera 15 heures dans telle
rue il sera tout seul et ce sont des
appels malveillants parce qu'évidemment
c'est pas pour déposer des fleurs et des
chocolats et donc ça oui nous allons
mieux le condamner grâce à ce projet de
loi merci beaucoup merci merci' avant
d'avoir été notre invité sylvain en
regardant une de ouest france stéphane
où sont les sites de production des
vaccins en europe
c'est la question à la une de ouest
france et marlène schiappa ge précise
que votre audition demain devant les
sénateurs sera diffusé en direct sur
notre antenne à 14h40
merci mais raisonner avec j'en ai
[Musique]